[Music]
so I would like to make four points in
two minutes
so after minute [ __ ] so I start with
something that was said also this
morning as a summary of some of the
workshops related to this topic and in
particular the statement that I think
that humans have value and that there is
what was called this wealth floor
meaning that our children and our people
that will come I have the same rights to
ever life as we had or even more so to
me humans have values also relates to
some of the points that maybe joy made
in some of these paper for example that
I don't think that everything that we
are can be reduced completely into a
machine so that means that we have some
values there that cannot be completely
embedded into a machine and also that
there is no race between us and the
machine I think more of AI as something
that should have meant and should
improve our ability to be humans rather
than being on a race with us so that
goes to my second point is that most of
the AI force that I see going around in
companies or in academia and so on are
to create machines that are augmenting
or extending our own intelligence our
own capabilities so if you take humans
out of this picture then it doesn't make
sense to build a yeah or we should we
should have another goal because if our
goal is really to build a technology
that augments our capabilities then the
human cannot be taken out of the loop so
the human should continue to be there
and being you know improved and
supported by machines the third point is
related to what also some of the
vision that you had put forward this
morning in his talk you may remember the
Stewart's
was proposing this methodology and
vision of probably even officially I
which is going to realize human
preferences which is going to learn more
preferences out of being you know having
uncertainty and so on and so to
understand human preferences and achieve
our own goals so in that vision if we
buy that vision then of course humans
should be there should continue to be
there yes and the last one is to give a
bit of nuance to my position is that yes
we should continue to exist but in some
sense we are already augmented and
merged a little bit because our watch
our telephone you know maybe they are
not internal to us they are external to
us but are already something that are
documenting us so shortest log on a
human centric I I hey my short slogan is
upload superpowers there's a lot of
reasons I would want to be uploaded I
don't want to get old I don't want to
die I don't want the people around me
that I love to die but there's also
other weird superpowers that are like
pretty different than that you know I
like to introspect I like to understand
you know why why I did something I'd
like to be able to read my code in that
introspection
I'd like to deeply connect with other
people right that's like a thing that
that we value a lot as humans and I'd
like to have higher bandwidth
interaction and ability to share why why
I believe something and why I'm doing
something I'd like to augment I'd like
to become smarter right and I'd like
that to be something you know I could do
principle in a principled way and that
other people have access to a weird
thing that came up in the discussion was
like a kind of radical privacy that you
could get this is mostly just give a
flavor of the other kinds of superpowers
you might get or you know I could say
you know I could have a I could have a
disagreement with somebody and be like
well I have some things I'd want to keep
I have it but we can spin up copies of
herself and we can have this too and and
you know our copies can talk and then
your copy can just tell you like is are
things cool like should you just let
this thing slide and and I can maintain
my privacy and then uh you know another
kind of like another orthogonal
superpower I would like is just to be
able to be in bliss right now you know
and if I want to stay in bliss that's
fine if some people stay in bliss
forever I feel okay with that
but you know I think I'd come back and
and do other stuff too
and so you know to clarify this is
assuming we're in a post super
intelligence world I don't I want to
ignore whether or not it's desirable to
push towards that world and I want some
guarantee that biological humans still
have like can still exist and get some
meaningful economic share I don't want
them to all be destroyed or something
but I I want to be uploaded so if we had
a super intelligence that had already
stabilized the world then this is
something I would ask for I'd be like
okay can you help us get uploaded now I
want I'd like those super powers I'd
like to stay relevant first of all be
careful about what you say on your
survey because I did a survey a few
weeks ago and now I'm finding myself
here to support in a position I'm not
that sure they're so strong so I think
that there's some responsibility but so
this morning there were some arguments
in favor of replacement Peter gave some
argument some discussion yesterday and
yeah so I will just give you the reason
why I chose replacement which are kind
of naive but the first thing is that I
think replacement as a kind of a very
natural process so we are replaced by
our children species are replaced by
other species and even galaxies are
replaced by some other galaxies and even
Ray Kurzweil will be replaced so I think
that that's a kind of a natural thing
and so the question is if we want to
stop it we have to be very issued at
what we want to
basically what we want to preserve do we
want to preserve human beings as they
are with their DNA as a kind of a DNA
stock we want to keep as it is do we
want to preserve life do we want reserve
intelligence do we want to preserve
civilization do we want to preserve
experiences and if we want to preserve
experiences do we want to preserve
future current past experiences people
who we left behind it we maybe we can
recover in some way or maybe we should
be censoring ourselves so that we might
be recovering someday so there are many
different questions and depending these
questions we should answer these humans
should be around in different ways and
the second reason I think I used to
sister choose this is purpose and I
think that in many of these scenarios
you have but you can you can see some of
the centers in Max's book about this and
I swear you humans are still around in
many of them especially when you take
that one about let's keep everything as
conservative as possible or the other
one will have these visas and areas
where you have a zoo or something like
that and I think I agree with some of us
and I wait to go into a different
direction but in the end they will
change human nature so radically that I
would call that a replacement so even
for those scenarios I think that for in
some of the ascend either you can't let
things go as they and for instance
jessic think in terms of evolution
evolution without a selective pressure
could end very badly it would be in
terms of evolution II kind of like so
basically I think that it's an open
question just to think about what we
want us to be replaced with or by and I
think this is a very interesting
question and of course that's compatible
to say okay we are not prepared so just
put let's press the brake and think what
we are doing that's completely
compatible but in the long term or in in
the long run I think that something that
perhaps is going to happen anyway
so my slogan I think is replacement is
natural
okay okay so I've been tasked with
pitching you that you should merge with
AI like we have a choice look guys we've
got no better option
I mean uploading seriously kill yourself
and run a simulation instead that's
great but you're dead it's not you in
bliss look I mean fundamentally the
problem is this we stock as a species
let's admit it we're pretty lame
like we don't run faster we don't swim
better we don't fly better you know our
foreign language capability sucks thank
God for Google Translate facial
orientation sucks thank God for Google
Maps numbers suck math sucks logic sucks
multitasking sucks our 360-degree
awareness sucks we have bad memories we
have poor perception we have attention
deficits we have an serious inability to
see things from multiple perspectives
we cannot be trusted why why on earth
would we not want something better I
mean like let's become something more
trustworthy and more sustainable right
but you know like we being you know yeah
I've granted they're a bunch of
alternatives like we could get replaced
right but then like so all this
enhancement is only for our AI children
I mean that's all nice and everything
but look we're still dead just stay as a
human
I mean unvented that's lame I just think
okay I just want you to think when all
your material needs can be satisfied you
don't need money what do you want you
want respect you want esteem you want
affection you want love forget the
stupid Hollywood grotesque depictions of
cyborgs like the Borg or whatever that's
stupid
just think how sexy you could be
merging is sexy you have a chance to
respond I will see them
merging is a kind of replacement in the
end depends on the scale and if it is an
individual scale oh it is just a global
scale basically you look ahead probably
you are thinking of something so rut so
radically different then you would call
you wouldn't call that human anymore
I'm glad I've already convinced you yeah
so what's the difference that's that's
my point saying that instead I would not
use the word merge I would use the word
of mine think you know expanding but we
are already I went in extending that we
will continue to be and that's our call
in the I not return user so those a
little bit that direction is done so we
are yeah I think uploaded entity should
have the decision as to whether or not
to merge I think it'll the uploading is
the step you want to take so that you
can then decide it's like the
incremental step and then then you
decide and once you might merge you
might want to unmerge you might be like
I was weird in there I think you would
want that option I'd love to hear you
debate your own self on that I got a
question for the upload camp and so I
guess there's an assumption that that
your identity or your youness or what
you care about is independent of the
substrate that you exist upon and so
what what gives you confidence such that
of that substrate independence you might
you might think that intelligence can
exist on different substrates
but-but-but you're actually making a
stronger argument that the the substrate
is equivalent in all valuable and
functional basis what gives you the
confidence of that uh yeah I mean I
think I think that's a technic and it
sounds like a hard technical problem but
I think it's a technical problem
um I guess like to imagine a test I
might want to see happen is what I would
like it imagine happening as a bunch of
people start getting uploaded they're my
friends and I start interacting with
them I'm like man they seem like still
my friends and but they're like really
fast and they've got a bunch of dope
things going on and so if I I think
there's kind of like a friend Turing
test like the people who know you best
if they still seem to think you're you
that that then at least when you go to
this new place you're not alone and it's
not a guarantee of the sort you're
looking for but it's it's enough like
the kind of evidence I'd expect you to
actually observe and that's a kind of
thing that I could imagine making me
confident that I would want to be
uploaded so a lot of the question around
whether or not you'd want to be replaced
seems to matter a lot on your timeline
not like I'm lying like thirty or fifty
years but more timelines like do we want
the human species be replaced in this
century or do we want the human species
to be replaced like and thousand years
from now because 10,000 years from now
like I don't know how humans are gonna
be like I have way less eight and that
so can you say something about like is
it is it that you don't want humans to
be replaced like when we get AGI in the
near term or is this like a very long
term question yeah I'm more like a long
term oh that's my perspective I think
that at the moment we know we know so
little about what is going to come that
I wouldn't just take such an important
step without knowing all the
consequences never we never know the
consequences and maybe this is a but for
many other scenarios I can see that I
don't see these are variants of a very
stable scenarios either they end up with
extinction and I don't like it or they
end up in something that changes human
nature radically but I'm thinking
long-term as a nature and I don't like
this idea let's stop everything and
let's keep like seeking these kind of
communities they're going against the
technology we know them and I don't like
that option that's an option but I don't
like that option when are we talking
about what we want to happen to humans
then it seems like a decision that can
be made for each individual human
separately maybe someone wants to merge
and someone else has to be uploaded and
so on who would you all agree that the
best feature is one where issue and can
choose what happens to them as opposed
to having one of these options and if
forced on them are not having a choice
why don't you put your thumbs up if it's
yes I mean yeah totally and I think if
we ran that experiment now you'd see
who'd win anyone want to disagree with
that just humans do you want to disagree
okay
yeah I think the voluntary system
doesn't work at all once you create
entities then they have a moral right to
exist and they have power in the world
and then if you decide later oh well we
made a mistake then you can't those are
those are irreversible decisions though
and if it's allowing a purely voluntary
big my you know the merged might
out-compete the Augmented they might you
know be just vastly more powerful that
the these people cannot cannot interact
in a meaningful economic or a societal
way and certainly not in a democratic
way though yeah so monetary doesn't work
because their power disparities and once
and it's an irreversible decision I'm
auntie
so I mean I think there's a thing I'm
trying to like crystallize this question
that some of these questions they're
dancing around right like sick how much
of you can you merge or how much AI can
you merge into you and you are still you
right you can do all the plastic surgery
in the world and you're definitely still
you but if I start implanting better
spatial orientation and faster math and
all that kind of stuff would you be
convinced that you're still you as
opposed to uploading a simulation into a
totally different piece of hardware
there wasn't one of these pictures about
children this morning we all loved doing
it but when I was a time this is lost
this is love to have some memories but
this is love so basically I write
replays myself even if I reckon make
recognize my pictures I'm not that
person and I'm doing that with them I'm
transforming all the time and I'm
forgetting things so in a way we are
transforming ourselves so we don't even
need AI to have these questions about
yeah if you are still the same person on
the economic relevance or like you know
potentially relevance thing I think all
right I'm just kind of want to assume
that the super intelligence can help
figure out an economic system that like
at least gives it's like say say you
stay human in biologically human you
know you're gonna have less economic
well ability to create economic value
but you should still be you know
post-scarcity and and and and have
enough economic wealth to be flourishing
and that seems like there should be just
enough wealth where you can guarantee
something like that because I mean
economic value is one thing but maybe
there are other metrics that we want to
use and maybe some of those metrics are
related to the fact that you months as
humans have value you know our mented or
not and so if there is a value that we
should we should go for it
even if it's not economically I think
some agreement that in the end we would
like to preserve the human race even if
it is as a record or in a more involved
where you're replaced way but that
allows us to preserve the past future
and thank you Carla
[Applause]
[Music]